我覺得這個邏輯特別好
因為我來有飯吃沒有飯吃
沒必要先做的
我們的護神就是成裡面
沒啥值得搶的東西
其實這裡面還有更簡單的方法論
我把你做的薯墓
然後你包括你做的小包桶
然後還有這個木部
不代
那你如果做成理一個的話
那可能是運氣
一個又一個的話
可能是有原因
可能是我方法論的
然後我們大家分享一下
你創業的方法對面
創業裡面其實受我的喝口人一家很大
我覺得這裡面很有
一大半的功勞
都要歸功於他
對那今天我就是帶他來講
你講
我覺得第一個點
其實是當時他的選擇
今天既然我們剛才說的
我們要不容資
我們要獨立
我們是一個商業公司的
所以第一件事
就是要找到一個持續存在的需求
比記這事看著說
當然會覺得說
那倒不性感
不是大賽道沒有風口
但你反過來看這個需求
他次來文字之後的意思是什麼的
是的
他不可能在說
AI來的時候
這需求都不在了門
他形勢會變需求補變
在這項比如說
在過10年我們還是要喝水
在過10年我們還是要吃飯
是說形勢會變
所以第一你找到一個補變的需求
因為有很多需求
未必是很能是委屈小
比如說
你在沒有智能手機之前
你是沒辦法想像
可能現在今天的很多這種
所以的基於地理為止的那個服務
明年而作
但是你說這筆機是存在的
所以你先找到一個補變的需求
然後你去保需求為真
對那你就像那一堆變讓你們
恩死了一個變量 對吧
第二件事是
在這個需求裡面
他是不是壟斷
比如說你看有無數人想去挑戰
那個微信的這個東西
或者想去挑戰一個社交網絡
但你發現你沒辦法挑戰
對
給他是壟斷的
但是比基這個市場是沒有壟斷
那這裡面就代表說
投資人很能不喜歡
因為他覺得說我投了你
你可能賺不到什麼錢
因為他不能壟斷
但對於小創意者來講
聽好呀 對吧
對他都有口飯吃
對
我記起來也有我一口飯吃
雖然我不能把這個飯都吃
飽但是我也沒能夠當
半心的東西這個邏輯特別好
就是我來有飯吃
沒有飯吃
沒必要先做的
你們都被車來救我吃
對…
你這個很好
然後你就會緊急奶牛骨
加鳳嗎
然後第三件事就是
他是一個長坡保血的事情
然後呢
這種我們經常
別人會問你們的護徵合士
什麼
我們今天會說
我們的護徵合就是
成裡面沒啥值得搶的東西
因為
很多時候我們覺得護徵合
就是我裡面要進行採訪
你好啊 對吧
我建議很大的逼勒
但多時候時候護徵合士相對的
因為我們當時是這樣說的
就是
如果你特別小了
因為我們兩個
縮混濃力足夠強
就賺兩個人的罷修的
是做完當時的
如果你是一個新型的穿腸腸腸腸的
你的成本一定高過我
對吧
如果你去融資這個市場太小了
然後呢
你未必能拿得到錢
你拿得到
對…
你拿到錢的話
其實你也這麼多錢
你可能投資人投了
你不是都不再投下來的
好了
然後如果是大公司
那這更簡單
就是逃不住
我熬個兩三年
像每一看
像什麼小市場就做做了
所以我們都會覺得說
好像我們的一個競爭優勢
就是我們的成本非常低
是的
然後我們
也沒…
就是這個市場
不是那麼好
所以長波保血
反而能讓我們活下來
對 這是可能一些
我覺得我們做的事情
一系列都是這個
就是總結束的這些
行採訪了
我們想過寫一些
不是出發這項
那個街層不累得一樣
我一直在替我的喝火熱
那些
那大鋼的小瓦
那些是很累的事情
把它放在小包圖上
我一直在送用
就去把這個玩
因為我們覺得還是挺有意思的
對
我覺得在這個公眾中
以發出來
然後再互動反饋
然後再不斷地去調整
我覺得這個確實是
這次累得和DITX
我們做了一個很好的榜樣
它既可以
既可以傳遞一些東西
我自己做產品
就是受大陸海底
還是能影響就非常大
所以我你看這些東西
這是剛才講了一個
持續存在的需求
當然你還好最好你喜歡
那個需求
還是這個剛才沒提的
我看一下服務
就是你們自己的自然
對我們很喜歡
然後幫我做小包圖
因為我自己就是一隻小文章
喝咐費的新文
請問有建築
所以你就順利成長就做這事嗎
對你一個持續的需求
你喜歡
然後就是長潑寶雪
然後別人也不會進來
給你搶
然後就不是一個隆斷的市場
那就換紙
然後你把車門控制的DIT
然後你自己的能力又很強
那就相當於是
短期內你就會有一些存活之地
那我們就能活下來了
我發現你們都有站有一個特點
我一個特點特點特點好
就是我去做煙事
然後做煙事的話
然後我會有總結
然後我會有數據的流存
然後根據我數據的流存
根據我的總結
本身就是我去做的煙事情況
我會自然生長出這麼一個產品
或者說順帶著這麼一個
是
因為我需要別人可能也需要
我覺得像一個像無論是
無論是小包圖也好
還是服務也好
我一個都是這樣
所以我很喜歡這樣的產品
對
所以有時候我們都說
所以那本書到偽大不能被計畫嗎
就很多時候
你都那無子理想
和你實際在生活中是不一樣的
所以你真的進到這些環境裡面
有很多奇蹟慢慢的事情你就過來了
就像我自己的當時
就AI來的時候
那GPG35的時候
然後你做福羅莫之前
你是沒想到會有這麼一個東西
逐漸的
對吧
包括GPG48或今天的東西
所以我覺得那你是進來之後
你不進去你外不知道
你進去之後才能感知到這些
水暖壓現的值漫
你剛才提到
偽大不能被計畫
我前一段時間知道
看個類似的那個
來誰的女兒
我了個類似
他寫了一篇文章
就如何成就一件偽大的事
然後他就提到一個什麼概念
他說
我去找到一個我喜歡的是
但是你在那外面看你啥的看懂
你看明白
你覺得都是這樣
你會高度的衝向
是
高度衝向
我們中國人特別適合這個
是
然後你會發現
你去做的工程中
然後你就會發現
你深入進的時候
你就會發現
這個地方是個空白
那個地方是個空白
這個地方是個類似
然後你進入這個空白
你進入這個類似的時候
你就穿發現
這個東西
它是有點意思的
然後你就順手做出的東西
然後你就添補了這個
這種空白
這樣那個類似
其實很多時候是這樣
思二人的中間
其實這裡面還有一種更簡單的方法論
我如果也可以分享一下
第一是
你有沒有生活中
經常要用的特別難受的事
就是不順手
我順手
對吧
你像當時我用都是我很喜歡
這是
慢
有一點重
是什麼
大家懂嗎
對吧
有時候玩不好
連不著心手機
就太重了
我那時候就
我就做個簡單點的東西
我做完之後
這些同步過就行不行
對吧
所以也是一個
做符合用的一個角度
對
然後第一是
你有什麼你很喜歡
且不是你一個人
有這樣的困惑的
這是第一手
第二就是
你只不得不為他付錢
對
因為你想你不是很喜歡
他但你又不得不為他付錢
就說明你不得不
因為錢是一種投票
對你就會發現說
我今天在哪兒
我就一直在發現說
這事
能不能我自己做
能不能把它成本降下來
或者說
別人有這樣
因為
需求驗證為真
是的
對
然後我就這也是一種新的事的
是
它是一個很訓習的方法
很假的事的
我在什麼地方花過錢
花了錢了
你玩哪個地方不說
花了
對
來我還在成分用他
好了
可以了
因為你一直
重複你就知道說
這不爽
為什麼他
就死我不敢
那可能就是你說的
分析就出來
那就花了
那麼就讓我們自己來吧
對
所以做一個創作者
這個事
其實我認為是
很基础的東西
我們反彈過很多人
我發現作為一個
創作的
他們總是能找到機會
總是能出現一個
用一個的產品
是
但是很奇怪的
就是我們大多分是消費者
對
因為這個我覺得
可能大家會把創新創造
創業創作
這個事
看得太冷凍了
對
很大
它沒有那麼的
沒有那麼的
腐臺
很冷藏的
我跟你講
很好玩的例子
就是
就是我們
一些小的創新
或者一些物區
我們
我們當時做醫療的時候
有一個特別搞笑的點
就是
我今天後面是問一個問題
你
如果去發傳單
做推廣
你會去哪
如果我去做我們發傳單
對
發傳單就是來推廣我們的產品
陣陣問人
對
你會去哪
我都要看我的用戶的
我都要猜我的用戶的
你會在哪
你第一反而就現在就
就是我們當時
護量往醫療
我就想問這個
什麼療是吧
第一個想法應該
其實是在醫院門口
重槍了
對
我們當時就去了
就是你就會發言說
他命嗎
在現場病
也挺難有病人
醫院有病人
我记很帅
然后呢
很多时候就带上停止了
或者认为这就是可以
记归已经我已经对完警察了
本来我们当时跑到胡州
加新跑到很多地方
然后去了
这没说
阿姨要不要再先问着
阿姨百姨神经病
我都坐在这儿
挂好好了
你让我在先问
然后第二款是
你定义吧
然后呢
好你们什么意愿
然后当时一刷出来
习近一月
习近月你知道的
就到我家旁边
不天气吧
在这边你想在加新的一个人
不知道习近一月是很正常吃的
但是
我们又不知道
它不知道
所以我们当时去一月
特别错摆的
所有人都觉得你们是神经病
对你们做这事
一点你都没有
对我人都来这儿
你在医生有什么
你能看花业吗
对
有体无数的问题
觉得这个也我要崩溃了
但是当时我们就后来
特别散的特别举散
后来我们就去那个周围
那个小吃汤
始统简
旁边是个学校
然后欢迎来点想一件事
我们意识到
我们当时平台上有一些人
一些年轻的女性
她老闻脸上
起都是问题
我们让我们去学校是
还去学校发现
这事反而通
因为你想
脸上起都是
不是不知语器原发的
好
这很反而麻烦
对吧
但是这些姑娘没有影响
都是我不好看了
我想解决这个问题
所以你跟她
你要花上面你就不聊
这可能是没分秘问题
你要不要问一下
我们这儿的医生都是三假的
那就是是被她发现
而且皮膚朋友是特别好解决的问题
所以你所谓的
创造创新
就是被小吃的一点点相似的
反而有些时候
我记得是谁说的
是雷军
还是李万强
李万强
小创造的
两个创新感
对 才有点
她提到过说
很多时候创新是从非主流人群
是的
然后开始的
所以我觉得
就是大家不要把创造的
这事是说
发明一个IT生有什么多的
那都被文学舞蹈了
其实很多时候发明创造
就这一点点小东西
写一篇文章
对
认真的写一篇文章
拍头视频
对
然后我今天
常试的做红烧肉的时候
加一点新的玩法
是
这其实就是创造
是的
从那种小子
创造开始
她讲成一种习惯
是的
这种习惯就在生活中部的那场
对
而且这时候你添不得一个
恋风就会有人
觉得说
中有一人八我想
表达是出来了
或者解决个问题
他就会给你赞上
对
很投票
有很多事
就是这样一点一点
开始给你赞会的
真心白银的投票
赞会是
这个才是很重要的